(jazzy trumpet)
- Where on earth is
Daner and Julier?
- Ew, you Hambumpers
have the worst B.O.
Get out!
- Uh!
- Eh!
- Biatches!
- Ham bump!
Smell me!
- Gross!
Now smell me!
- Sick!
Yay!
We reek!
That means puberty is here!
This is the most important
day of our lives!
- Yeah, but don't forget
class elections are today.
Ms. Klitnick nominated
me against Shelly.
- Fuck Shelly.
She may be the most popular girl
in the Learning
Zone cause of her
big, horny boobs but
I'll make sure you win!
- Listen up little children.
Julier and Shelly,
time for your campaign speeches.
To see who goes first,
I'm going to pick
names out of my new hat.
My hat, my hat,
so fuzzy, so black!
My hat.
- Is hat code for vagina?
(students laughing)
(pleasurably moaning)
(speaking foreign language)
- Isn't it plush?
I got it as a makeup
gift from my soulmate
Govindas, Dana's father.
- Jesus Christ on my dick!
Fucking gross.
Fuck all ya'll!
(motorbike revving)
- Titties be free!
- Shelly, you're up!
- If I get elected
I wanna focus on
school spirit!
(pom poms fluttering)
So, everyday we'll
practice a line formation
that turns into a spirit dance!
(pom poms fluttering)
Go St. Weinerbush Learning Zone!
Woo-hoo!
(speaking foreign language)
(cheering)
- Boo!
- Alright, I'm putting
my hand back in my hat.
So fuzzy, so thick.
My hat, so black.
(pleasurably moaning)
And our other candidate, Julia?
- Go Julia!
(classmates cheering)
- Uh, I wanna get us
a real, live sexual
education class that
teaches us how to put
a penis in a bush,
how to do orgasms
and how to keep
your husbands happy.
- Fuck yeah!
Big tits go boom boom boom!
- Oh, I'm so nervous, I think
I have to fart.
(farts)
- Oh!
- Sorry.
I think Shelly's gonna win.
She's already gone
through puberty 100 times.
- Yeah, she probably
sleeps in a vibrator.
Maybe you're right!
We need to make your
posters look more mature.
Follow my bush.
- Oh my god, awesome!
I look old as shit!
(bell ringing)
(classmates cheering
and laughing)
- Beauty!
Someone go to my
car and bring me my
Hamentashens and my
prenatal vitamins!
Wha?
Who?
This mishegas is vandalism!
Whoever did this must
not want Julia to win.
- It must of been Shelly!
- That is so disgusting.
And anyway mine are
straight and blonde, and--
- Shelly!
You are disqualified!
(Ms. Klitnick sobbing)
(Shelly sobbing loudly)
Oh Shelly!
How dare you do this
to Ms. Klitnick?
Govindas and I were
gonna donate our hair
to the JCC's Locks of
Love Lock-in tonight.
Shelly!
You are suspended!
Julia!
You're our new class
president, girl!
- Hooray!
- We rule the Learning Zone!
- Show me your president bush!
(both laughing)
- Ham bump!
(explosion)
♪ Girl I wanna do it!
♪ Dontcha wanna do it!
♪ Can we do it!
(jazzy trumpet)